[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator tv
and broadcast on thursday august 26th
i'm kate andrews the spectators
economics editor and your host this week
on this week's show joe biden says the
u.s will leave afghanistan for good on
august 31st despite boris johnson's plea
for more time will this damage the uk's
relationship with america and to what
extent will the west work with the
taliban
australia has a zero coveted strategy
melbourne a city of 5 million has gone
into lockdown because there are 70 cases
a day surely there's an alternative
extinction rebellion is on the march
again do their protests work and why
won't green group support nuclear power
and finally our columnist toby young
gives us his top travel tips if you're
staying in the uk this summer
before we get going if you enjoy what we
do here on spectator tv then subscribe
to our youtube channel for free just
click the button at the bottom of this
video and then tap the bell icon to make
sure you never miss an episode
and why not subscribe to the spectator
magazine too we've got a new special
offer for just 10 pounds you can get 10
weeks of the magazine delivered to your
door and available online along with a
bottle of pims or 25 pounds absolutely
free it's only available while stocks
last so go to spectator dot co dot uk
forward slash tv offer to take up the
offer now
now first joe biden has ignored please
from the g7 leaders and has confirmed
that the u.s evacuations and with it the
evacuation flights of everyone else will
end on august 31st thousands of afghans
who have served with our armed forces
could be left to the mercy of the
taliban
will this hurt the special relationship
and should we engage in diplomacy with
afghanistan's new regime to discuss i'm
joined by general sir david richards who
commanded the international coalition in
afghanistan between 2006 and 2007 and
was head of the armed forces between
2010 and 2013.
answer christopher mayer britain's
ambassador to the united states between
1997 and 2003.
david christopher thanks for joining us
on spectator tv
david we heard on tuesday that the prime
minister failed to persuade joe biden to
extend the withdrawal deadline past the
31st of august what's your reaction
i wasn't surprised at all um
it's you know i have some sympathy with
president biden and notwithstanding my
um
you know his great sadness at the
decision he took originally which
precipitated afghanistan into this
crisis um
you know it's all very well for other
countries to pester the us to stay on
uh but they would have to shoulder the
burden of whatever entailed and the fact
is it would
almost certainly precipitate some sort
of shooting war albeit on a maybe a
localized uh of a localized nature
around kabul airport if the taliban uh
didn't go along with it but the fact is
the taliban are calling the shots and he
doesn't want to risk that and i think
he's right
christopher many people have been
startled by biden's stubbornness on this
are you surprised that that g7 call
didn't get anywhere no i wasn't
surprised at all i i actually don't
think it's a very good way of trying to
persuade
the american president to change his
mind as i'm kind of ganging up on him by
smaller european states with far less at
stake in in kabul so i wasn't surprised
although i think there was a wobble
before the summit there was a moment
when he was suggesting suggesting that
maybe the decision could come under
review
um and then you had this weird meeting
in which there has been very little
written between the head of the cia bill
burns and i think it was number two in
the taliban
on monday after which the white house
position hardened the game and when i
say harden i mean hard against the
europeans we're pressing for an
extension and more or less
uh going along with the taliban so i
think there has been
a decision in washington to put a
premium on a practical pragmatic
uh cooperation with the taliban um and
as david says if we'd gone beyond the
31st of august we ran the risk of a hot
shooting war reigniting and that i think
was the last thing that biden wanted
either from a foreign policy point of
view or a domestic policy point of view
and christopher what does this mean for
britain's diplomatic relationship with
the united states well
uh if you look at it in a long stretch
of history
not a lot necessarily i mean the
so-called special relationship which is
as you know a phrase which i really
dislike because i think it is inaccurate
highly rhetorical and raises
expectations that can't be met from both
sides of the atlantic
um there'll be many many bad patches
starting with the the war loan after the
second world war going through so is
going through harold wilson refusing to
send troops to vietnam when lbj asked
him to do so john major jerry adams is
visa granted by bill clinton these are
all tough moments in the british
american relationship is this a tougher
moment
than previous episodes not necessarily i
think the serious thing here is less for
the bilateral relationship between
britain and the united states it's much
more for the nature of the nato alliance
because let us not forget
that the only time in the history of
nato that article 5 an attack on one
shall be deemed an attack on all was
ever invoked
was after 9 11.
and the americans as i remember very
well because i was in washington at the
time were deeply grateful for that
now
uh
joe biden has drawn the curtains on what
was essentially a native operation
without even a bow
turn of the head
towards that original article 5 decision
so if i were sitting in nato
headquarters i'd be quite bruised
david
you've described the west as defeated in
afghanistan can you expand on that
well in a narrow sense that is what has
happened um
whether it was intended or not is
neither really here nor there so
um
you know they've come out not only
badly from it in a geostrategic sense um
internally within afghanistan our stock
at the moment is
incredibly low and rightly and
understandably so so i don't think you
can disguise it in any other way the
fact is we've been defeated uh that's a
debate about whether that was necessary
what i'd like to now concentrate on is
what are we going to do next what can we
do
to perhaps recover some influence within
afghanistan and most importantly start
putting the afghan people first and stop
looking back that is very interesting
and needs to be done but right now
those who count themselves as statesmen
and i think sadly we have a dearth of
that in the west that need to focus on a
strategy that will alleviate the current
situation concentrate where it can on
ensuring terror camps don't spread
spring up again and then getting
alongside the taliban and although it's
usually as a statement be about being
generous in victory i think this is one
of those very few occasions when we need
to be generous in defeat and i was very
quickly i was uh rather heartened by the
fact that isis have turned their backs
on the taliban going back as christopher
said to the cia chiefs visit i think
that's where the americans are now
putting their money they haven't
probably got any alternative and we need
to help the taliban sort of come in from
the cold and and focus as i said on the
afghan people and helping them get out
of the plight they're in well come on to
what may happen in the days and weeks to
come in the west's relationship with the
taliban but for a bit more historical
comparison david would it be fair to
compare america's exit from afghanistan
to britain's exit from basra and iraq in
2007.
no i don't think so i mean that was not
a happy uh episode for the british army
but yet again
armies are usually plunged into these
events through
political indecision or bad political
decision making
in the case of basra
they got out in quite good order
and uh occupied the airfield there for a
long time after that so i i don't think
it's fair uh and certainly the ga
strategic implications were minor
compared with what we're going to see as
a result of what's happening in
afghanistan there was insistence in 2007
that it wasn't a defeat do you think
we're going to see insistence from joe
biden now that it wasn't a defeat or do
you think there will be a more honest
conversation like the one you're having
in using that word uh in relationship to
afghanistan
it's a very good question i don't see
really how you can disguise it as
anything other than a defeat i mean
people might say that you know after 20
years it's time to get out and all that
sort of thing i don't agree with that i
think we've forgotten that these things
do take a very long time uh and i
remember in 2009 being asked by the bbc
um how long i thought we'd have to
remain committed to afghanistan and i
said then between 30 and 35 years
stressing i wasn't talking about being
in the combat role and i was sort of
pilloried but of course that is broad if
you have any sense of history that's
broadly the sort of time one has to
remain propping up a country what that
has got one has gone to help in these
situations and you have been in that
time frame a generational change and
we're seeing that happen now you know
the younger generation and those uh in
the urban population and that much now
much bigger proportion of the afghan
population do not want the taliban and
they they're different people but uh the
taliban through force of arms and guile
and great psychological as well as
military maneuver have gained the
ascendancy and are now in charge so
we've got to work through that but a
defeat i'm quite clear it was at the
strategic level uh soldiers were never
as far as i know defeated at the
tactical level but certainly at the
strategic level it is a defeat
christopher david's mentioned uh before
about how we may now need to uh work
with the taliban and interact with the
taliban in the future is there any space
for diplomacy here
well there may well be space for
diplomacy i actually think there is
always space for diplomacy uh one of the
problems one of the challenges
confronting the taliban is what they do
about their relationships with the wider
world it is not as if after august the
31st they will of necessity retreat into
a kind of hermit kingdom they won't do
that um they're much more sophisticated
as we have seen than they were 20 years
ago and as david has
has just said uh the
generations have changed there are
people with higher aspirations um who
will be left behind in afghanistan after
the end of the
end of this month so there is something
there to engage with what i do not
believe in is that they should be uh
left in a kind of frozen isolation
simply because their record on human
rights or this may stick in the crore of
many people
is is pretty poor
they will need to interact with the
outside world and the other thing
that
i don't believe is that
nature is now creating a vacuum nature
abhors a vacuum and when the vacuum that
we in the americans and the other nato
allies have
left behind i don't think of necessity
will be filled by conspiring
uh chinese or russians or iranians or
pakistanis because
the afghan hostility to foreign
uh subjugation to foreign occupation is
very very strong whoever comes into uh
afghanistan we go all the way back to
alexander the great whose ruins can
still be still be found in afghanistan
through the british in the 19th century
and the early 20th century god knows
even before this intervention we had
fought three afghan wars and we still
didn't draw the right political uh
conclusions from them i'm not talking
about military talking about political
conclusions
um
and uh i would be surprised to see
beijing moscow
uh
and other capitals rushing in
to fill the gap that we left behind
because
the russians under the soviet union have
been burnt once they're not going to be
burnt again the chinese are extremely
wary about afghanistan because of a
possible muslim connection uh with the
ouijas um in
inside inside china so i think there is
a lot to play for here
and one of the things that one of the
strategies i think we should consider
about afghanistan is not rushing in some
way to try to retrieve the situation try
and get back things that we have lost
but it may be that a strategy of mastery
inactivity is called before as that we
let things just come to
just
calm down afghanistan in and of itself
is not a particularly important country
and um
uh the notion
of actually
david mentioned his uh 30 35 years
actually i thought what he said was 40
years and i've often quoted him he
doesn't know this i have plagiarized him
in in in some speeches and some some
some comments that if you're going to
try and change the nature of a state as
opposed to conduct a punitive operation
against al-qaeda and taliban you've got
to be there for scores and scores and
scores of years
and the longer you stay the more you set
up resistance to your presence there um
i think that's one of the
one of the rules of life so
i think we should make haste slowly on
this um that would be the best approach
david if we can't get all of the brits
and vulnerable afghans out by the 31st
of august and the defense secretary ben
wallace has said that that is a likely
outcome then what should we do
i think we've got to be very
hard-hearted about it um certainly the
brits um while rightly we're talking up
the terrific uh performance of our armed
forces at kabul airport cannot do it by
themselves uh we are dependent on the
americans that's the situation that all
european nato countries as much as we
sort of bluster them planning on this
have got ourselves you know global
britain and all that um we cannot
operate independent in this sort of
environment without the americans so
if they won't we can't and indeed we're
likely to get out earlier and i i think
that is the right decision because the
alternative is risking um you know
combat again uh on the severe back foot
with the taliban i can't think of a
worse uh environment in which to do a
non-combatant evacuation than the one we
have now found ourselves in
you would never i don't think in a staff
college exercise you would actually get
there right it could be so bad but
that's how bad it is so i'm afraid we
have to leave them and maybe my advice
to my friends who are in this situation
is play it long
don't despair there will be other routes
out carved over time the afghans are
expert at this across land frontiers or
whatever
and just play it long and i'm sure
slowly the international community will
assist them in that uh
going down that route
david christopher thanks for joining us
to give us the latest on the uk
government's reaction i'm joined now by
the spectators assistant editor isabel
hardman
isabel the west is now openly working
with the taliban whether it's control
over the airport or in the case of the
u.s sharing intelligence about isis and
kabul is this the new reality diplomacy
between the west and the taliban
i guess it has been our reality for
a while actually that there have been
these channels of communication um
between uh western governments western
forces and the taliban but they're being
much more open about that
now as part of attempts to show that
they are doing everything they can to
evacuate as many people as possible
from afghanistan the question is i think
is what kind of channel of communication
is there going to be
after the 31st of august because you are
still going to have a lot of people in
afghanistan who don't feel safe who want
to get out of the country
who may have the papers and be entirely
eligible to leave but who due to the
chaos of the evacuation effort over the
past few days and the fact that it is
going into its final hours now are just
not going to be able to get out and
boris johnson and other g7 leaders said
earlier this week that they wanted the
taliban to secure to guarantee them a
safe passage out of the country that
will involve necessarily some kind of
communication between uh governments and
the taliban although again boris johnson
has been talking about the need for a
coordinated international
response to the taliban so there's not a
sort of unilateral recognition of
this new government by one particular
country and that actually all countries
have to act together so there's really a
question about how they're going to
negotiate the taliban have been very
bullish in saying that actually they're
not going to let afghans leave that they
want these people to stay to help build
their country and so you can see that
there will be a lot of tooing and
throwing
over
this safe passage and how on earth the
g7 are going to police that is not at
all clear
what's your instinct about how far the
uk government might push this would the
uk be in support of international
recognition of the regime for example
well they've said that they will only
consider international recognition if
the taliban abide by uh human rights
obligations now i mean
that's uh that's pretty difficult to see
how that's going to to pan out in the
long term given the taliban are already
telling women to stay at home claiming
that that's for their own safety while
they ensure there's enough security um
in the country but
you can see how there may never be
enough security for women to go back to
work and live the lives that they've
been living for the past
two decades so at what point do uh
countries say well actually no things
aren't just obviously going backwards
but actually people's human rights are
being contravened i mean you could say
right now that's happening because uh
people are being stopped and beaten at
checkpoints now is is that something
that's compatible with international
human rights obligations i i'm not sure
so at what point do countries say okay
they've crossed the line
have they already crossed the line at
which point you don't recognise the
taliban at which point there's a much
more hostile relationship
so what's the view in government about
the situation with afghanistan boris
johnson failed in his effort to persuade
biden to extend the withdrawal deadline
as you've mentioned there may not be
enough time to get people out how is
that going to be dealt with in whitehall
after the 31st of august
yeah i think there's there's a lot of
angst in whitehall and you can see and
hear it in various ministers demeanor
when they're doing broadcast interviews
that they are really upset actually by
what they are trying to deal with uh
i've spoken to a lot of mps as well who
have been bombarding these ministers
with cases absolutely
you know
terrible cases of families who have been
stranded
with either without the right
documentation when they are
definitely eligible to get out of the
country or who have had to go into
hiding because they tried to go through
the airport and
were beaten i know of one family who um
their children witnessed other children
um being shot at in front of them and
are now so traumatized they're not
speaking and you know these are just a
couple of cases and there are thousands
of thousands of thousands of these cases
being brought to ministers by individual
mps so i think there's a a lot of
emotional um anguish in uh certain parts
of whitehall and in terms of what
happens after the deadline i mean
there's there's not really uh much
discussion for i think uh quite
understandable reasons
about what happens to the people who are
at kabul airport
once troops have left we've had the
warning from both the uk and the u.s
overnight that
that people should leave kabul airport
because of an imminent terror threat but
people aren't because they think that
there might just be a chance that they
get on um a flight at the very last
minute and so you are as troops
disappear as the planes disappear as the
flights come to an end you're going to
have thousands of desperate people just
at the perimeter of the airport and
ministers are
understandably i think dodging questions
on on what might happen to those people
um they've obviously signaled to the
taliban that they want to get out of the
country that they may in some way be a
sort of high value target
because they've worked for a human
rights organization or with the afghan
government and so on and there's very
little discussion about that because
partly ministers don't know what's going
to happen but also that the best guess
of what's going to happen is is not a
pretty one
lastly isabelle the deterioration in
afghanistan has been one of the only
topics over the past 17 months that has
diverted our attention away from kova
19. but with hospitalizations creeping
up and autumn around the corner what are
the conversations going on in government
we heard at the beginning of the summer
about the possibility of another winter
lockdown certainly more restrictions is
that still a possibility
yeah there's definitely anxiousness uh
about what the winter is going to look
like not least because as i've been
writing about this week there's a summer
crisis in the nhs already at the moment
you've had a number of hospitals around
the country
issuing black alerts which is basically
the highest level of alerts saying that
they're not going to be able to provide
comprehensive treatment and that patient
safety might be compromised and that's
not just because there's a relatively
high number of people with covid in
hospital at the moment it's just under
seven thousand i think at the last
count but it's also because a lot of
people who have been sick during the
pandemic during the lockdowns are now
starting finally to present to hospital
and they're much sicker
than they would normally be when they
presented out of pandemic
times and so you've got record demand
for a e you've got record calls going to
the ambulance service and this is the
summer this is before we get the normal
winter respiratory uh illnesses such as
flu such as rsv which is an illness that
children
uh often get but haven't got because
their viral loads their immune systems
haven't been
stimulated in the way that they normally
are with the normal sort of level of
activities that children do it's before
we have the schools in england returning
as well you've already seen a warning in
scotland from nicola sturgeon as the
scottish schools have now been back for
a week
that if people don't limit their
unnecessary social contact she may have
to re-impose restrictions and there is
an anxiety and a door has been left open
uh in england that the this will have to
happen again in the autumn
as numbers go up and the nhs really
struggles to cope
isabel thanks so much for joining me
while australia is dealing with this
question by taking a zero covet approach
they want to completely eliminate the
virus from the country in this week's
cover piece alexander downer the foreign
australian foreign minister writes that
his country is quote trapped in a
seemingly endless cycle of lockdowns
what's the way out
to discuss i'm joined by alexander and
professor andrew lee a public health
expert from the university of sheffield
alexander in this week's cover piece you
write that australia has been scared
witless by covid creating a zero copied
prison for itself what's happened
well basically the problem with
australia is that first of all when
cobit broke out in china the government
banned flights
between australia and china and closed
the country off from
people traveling into australia as best
it could there are obviously some
limitations to that
and this policy had early success but
secondly um there are two problems that
have arisen first of all
um the state premiers the state
governments and the heads of those
governments uh premiers
took the view that they should achieve
zero covert not that the government's
governments should just flatten the
curve and make sure the health system
could cope with the impact of covert but
there should actually be no covet
allowed in their states at all
in order to achieve that they have had a
succession of lockdowns and the closure
of borders between the states
so in australia is one country but
people can't visit their family and
friends in other states often
sometimes they can but often they can't
because of the borders being closed and
the problem with this approach is that
not only is it having a huge social and
economic impact on the country
but ultimately it is doomed to fail
because it is not possible for australia
to achieve zero covert and only now as i
talk to you are australians beginning to
wake up to that and understand the huge
health
mental
economic societal impact of this
constant flow of lockdowns that take
place in australia
andrew this is the zero covet approach
that you once supported can you briefly
outline the thinking behind it the
reason that some people continue to
support zero covered but also what's led
you to recently question your own
opinions on it
okay well i think let's start with the
idea of a new emerging pathogen that's
highly infectious and highly deadly
such as ebola or indeed sars in the
early days and the australian experience
and the new zealand experience has shown
that quick rapid action
robust action
does work to limit the spread of
infection
and if you look at the number of deaths
that australia's had compared to the uk
if not for the measures they've had
taken they're probably looking at
something like 40 50 000 deaths in the
past year which they've not had so
nothing to detract from the efforts and
sacrifice that the australians have have
done um the issue however as alexander
has uh claimed outline is in the longer
run in the longer term um this isn't
likely to work especially now that we've
got a variant in the delta variant
that's so much more infectious
as well as
pretty prevalent infections right across
the world
so this calling the question can
countries like australia taiwan new
zealand continue to wall themselves off
indefinitely and at what cost
andrew do you think if we were still
dealing with the original strain of the
virus not the delta variant that there
would be more of an argument to commit
to zero covid even for
six months a year two years more for
these
countries that are more easily able to
do it given their geographical location
or do you think even with the original
strain this question was always going to
come to a
head um i think this
issue was always going to surface um
uh with
whichever strain we had really um
i would say that the the challenge of
addressing the original strain uh being
less infectious with an effective
vaccine uh the the possibility of
achieving that would have been much
easier whereas now i just think um that
boat has sailed and and
it's a bridge too far really
alexander in the magazine this week as
well sasha o'sullivan writes about her
plight as she's an australian living in
the uk and how she doesn't even know
she'll be able to get home for christmas
2022. in her article she mentions some
harrowing examples of what's been going
on in australia there's even an example
of a mother being torn apart from her
prematurely born child
who she wasn't able to see in the icu
because they deemed her to be too much
of a risk despite testing negative on
multiple occasions for covid19
yet the australian public is still
behind these restrictions you cite a
poll in your article saying that most
would support closing the borders if
there were just 25 cases um so is this a
case of the government overstepping
and being too heavy-handed because
they're in a position to be able to do
so or is it the case that the government
is simply responding to what people seem
to want
well the first thing is it's governments
not government this is part of the
problem with australia that there's the
federal government and then there are
the state governments the federal
government's responsible for the
external borders quarantine but the
actual health systems are run by the
states and they have the constitutional
responsibilities for them
the federal government had a system of
quarantine where the states
which was administered by the states
where australians coming back into the
country and non-australians visiting
australia who might have got permission
to do so
were put into
a hotel room for 14 days not allowed out
of the room
um but just stay in the hotel room for
14 days um so that was that was pretty
draconian um but nevertheless people
could go home on that basis then the
state governments decided because they
have a zero covered strategy
that
occasional cases of covert were escaping
from these quarantine hotels as they
were called many hotels
so occasional cases of kobe were
escaping so they should reduce the
number of people who are able to use
those hotels
and so now um you know only 3 000 people
a week are about to go into australia
and there are um something like a
million australians who live out of the
country and so and the other side of
that is you have to pay to go into the
medi hotel that's three thousand dollars
for the 14 days that's around 1500
pounds for the 14 days
and you can imagine the cost to a whole
family of that
and over and above that there are very
few flights into australia it's very
hard for people to get onto a flight and
they are hugely expensive the flights
it's important to remember that so i
mean you've got a situation where they
where the governments state and federal
governments are effectively saying um
that um
you know only in the most limited of
circumstances
um are australians able to return to
their own countries i mean you know your
mother might be dying or your child
might be very ill or um you might just
want to reunite with your family as you
might normally do say around christmas
or easter or whatever it is
um but it's it's not impossible but it's
nigh impossible and you certainly have
to have a lot of money to do it
um and i mean cost thousands and
thousands of dollars to buy an air
ticket if you can get one and then
you've got your three thousand dollar
quarantine
and so it it's really just for the rich
and by the way they're very patient
because you have to wait for months
until you can get onto a plane
so all of this
is in
the cause of zero covert
um and of course you know as andrew is
suggesting an answer to your previous
question um this is a policy that can
never succeed it's true
that not many people have died in
australia um with covert as compared to
say the uk that is true
but
the game is not over yet
and um
since xero covert can never work
ultimately it's not going to work
there are going to be cases where
particularly the elderly and the frail
do die with copen
and you're seeing that now in new south
wales i mean every day three or four
people are reported to have died they
typically frail people they're elderly
people
but to put that into some perspective 3
000 australians die every week i'm
afraid australians die they're not
immortal
andrew you've now said that there's only
one realistic end game and that will be
accepting that kovid will become endemic
can you talk us through that and can you
also lay out how close australia and say
the uk
might be to reaching this
okay
well this is a tricky one um because
we're not quite sure whether this virus
has kind of reached a degree of
stability and found its ecological niche
um
it will indeed become an endemic virus
which will continue to circulate in
human populations from here on out
um and we will get probably seasonal
outbreaks you know
it's a
it's cousins the other human
coronaviruses are winter viruses so
wouldn't surprise me we start to see
that pattern
and here's where the challenge for us
is is how do we mitigate how do we
reduce the impact of this virus when you
get those seasonal outbreaks and
vaccinations the key so
alexander has mentioned that a lot of
deaths are in the vulnerable elderly
that was certainly what we experienced
here in the uk
so australia is in the race against time
race against the virus to get its
vaccinations as high as it can to
protect those vulnerable individuals
as you mentioned there
many countries i mean most countries i
think now view vaccination as the answer
to our coven 19 woes
but there's still lots of questions i
mean it very much appears in places like
israel and the uk which were world
leaders in rolling out the vaccine that
the vaccines are working very very well
to break the link between infection and
hospitalization which i think many would
argue is is the most important factor
and on that front vaccines are working
but there is new data coming out of
places like israel that suggests that
immunity from impact from vaccination
isn't lasting as long as we might have
hoped now that isn't necessarily the end
of the world especially if you're going
to focus on hospitalizations
over infections but if you're going for
xerocovit i mean that's not going
vaccines won't be your solution because
you're going to have to accept that even
with vaccinations there's going to be
certain level of infection um so is this
something that australia is just going
to have to come around to inevitably
that even with vaccinations even with
the solution that we have in front of us
they're going to have to accept some
level of cover cases
indeed i mean this is contingent on
whether a vaccine can block the spread
of infection and and what all the
studies have shown so far is that it's
not
that effective at blocking infection
it does reduce the risk of of the severe
outcomes of death and severe disease
needing hospitalization so let's not
take away from that
but we know that it is not
very powerful in blocking the spread of
infection so consequently
to use it as a as a measure to stop the
spread it's not going to be
very successful if you see what you mean
sure and and and that's fundamentally
going to be the the problem isn't it
that if you're going for a zero covet
strategy and you're going to have to
rely on lockdowns indefinitely because
the vaccines while very successful and
those important metrics aren't going to
get you to zero covet
indeed indeed so
that's kind of why i'm saying that in a
sense the objective of the game has now
changed it's about trying to minimize
the damage caused by the vaccine on
human populations uh sorry the virus on
human populations and so there's
hospitalizations that's deaths in our
most vulnerable members of society
that's what we need to do get the
vaccines out to protect them alexander
how close do you think the australian
government is to accepting this argument
um so i think the australian government
as in the federal government
more or less does accept that argument
as andrew just articulated it but i do
not think the state governments
have reached that point particularly the
governments of queensland
south australia western australia they i
don't think they've really realized this
um and and it's as simple as this um
the
vaccination roll out is happening in
australia very late
um and it's happening very late partly
because there was a huge scare campaign
run
on the impact of astrazeneca
so people stopped getting vaccinated on
the grounds that well
the australian
government had made an arrangement with
astrazeneca to produce astrazeneca in
melbourne
so there was initially quite a good flow
of astrazeneca
but
they were told that you could die from a
blood clot and there wasn't much covert
in australia not much risk of catching
covert so why would you take the risk of
having a vaccination so people didn't
have vaccinations and so the rollout has
started off being very slow it's getting
faster now but as andrew says
um
the vaccine
will very substantially reduce the risk
of
hospitalization or death i mean it will
have a huge impact as we've seen on that
but it won't stop
covert or covert dead in its tracks
there still will be covered and now the
state governments in australia are still
closing down the borders and closing
down locking down the whole of their
societies
on the grounds that there are a few
cases of coven here and a few cases are
covered there and they're telling the
public look once the vaccines rolled out
we won't have to do this anymore but of
course once the vaccine's rolled out 70
80 percent of people have been
vaccinated those are the targets
adults
once the vaccinations are rolled out
there still will be cases of covert and
occasionally sadly people will still die
with covert i mean covert is just going
to be one of the risks of life of which
there are many
um and australians are just going to
have to come to terms with that
protect the vulnerable as best they
possibly can roll out the vaccines as
well as they possibly can
but ultimately you cannot close the
country off indefinitely you cannot have
these constant lockdowns
the the lockdowns australia had a
wonderful economic record better than
any other developed country on earth
up until very recently but you cannot
you cannot indefinitely keep
financing all of these lockdowns and
this sort of madness
of trying to eliminate covert when
ultimately it will be endemic
andrew alexander thanks for coming on
now extinction rebellion has taken to
the streets again to push for more
urgent action to combat climate change
do their extreme tactics work and why is
there such a push back in the green
community to certain energy alternatives
i'm joined now by zeon lights zeon was
formerly a spokesperson for the group
but is now an advocate for nuclear
energy
zeon thanks for coming on spectator tv
you used to be a spokesperson for
extinction rebellion but left can you
tell our viewers what happened
there are a few different reasons why i
left the main reason was that they had
made
a claim that wasn't scientifically
accurate and they wanted to stand by it
and i think which made it very difficult
for me to be a spokesperson but the
other reason is that i think they did a
very good job in drawing attention
climate change
um but
i think the conversation has kind of
moved on from that now people are aware
of it and we could be talking about
solutions from what we can do next
rather than
um repeating the same message that you
know we just need to act without any
kind of direction
uh without giving any kind of direction
in which to act
you know it's interesting you say that
because i've felt that similar shift too
it feels like broadly across the
political spectrum now
everybody is concerned about climate
change everybody wants to tackle it so
the debate now is really how you go
about doing that and that can still be
controversial it can still be punchy but
it is a different debate isn't it
it is still controversial and actually i
don't think it's enough to keep saying
listen to the scientists um
most people
this is a very big statement and they
don't really know what it means
and we're still sort of making the same
arguments we've making for about
20 30 years which is just use less at
home just make little changes at home
and actually hasn't worked the world
continues to use and consume more than
ever before it's not going to work no
one has found a magical way to make
everybody use significantly less amounts
of energy and consume less actually we
just need to look at really practical
solutions and that's the bit where
everything could change because it would
actually be doing something different
and i think actually a lot of these
organizations think they're doing
something different by going out and
sitting down roads but the message is
exactly the same as it has been
and it really does need to move on now
so i want to come on to the solutions
that you think might work in a bit but
first when you left extinction rebellion
you wrote for the daily telegraph after
quitting that you didn't just want to
quote shout ever more loudly about the
problem so what's going wrong with the
current climate change debate in the uk
and how do you think the debate could be
improved
there is a lot of shouting um it's also
a very strange um imbalance of kind of
saying support the science follow the
science and then climate denial what
we'll find is a lot of um
additional environmental clears or
boomer environmentalists are very
against a lot of the solutions that
scientific consensus says we need but if
you look at the ipcc report the kind of
landmark report that came out in 2018
which galvanized against rebellion and
friday for the future to act
it does have a 97 memphis that climate
change is human cause okay
and all of these groups really push that
they really push that messaging the same
report if you go to the energy section
has
the same scientific consensus from the
same scientists has a section by working
group three which has four ways
the world to decarbonize and all of
those all of those scenarios include
nuclear energy and some of them the more
realistic ones use a significant amount
of nuclear engine actually if you look
at what's happening around the world
opposite is happening right most of
europe is shutting down its reactors
germany's phasing out its nuclear power
plants it's been doing that before even
phasing out coal
um you know and
there's lots of countries spain
netherlands
um
netherlands austria who signed up this
kind of anti-nuclear
uh ban basically they're back they're
banning it everywhere belgium as well
has banned it um and
that's so clearly going against the
science so it doesn't make sense to me
you've got all these protesters shouting
so the science
and there's this actual science denial
going on i mean it's the same report
that has a lot of the solutions in the
kind of mitigation section as well as
you know what the problem is and you
can't keep pointing at the problem and
saying fix it fix it fix it and then
deny deletions and actually i think this
is quite dangerous because it's the same
thing that's been happening okay it's a
big problem in the environmental
movement and it doesn't look like it's
going to change
i find there's this new divide in the
green movement between those you
mentioned consumption at the beginning
of the interview between those who think
that the way that we live our lives and
in many ways the progress that we've
made to bring people up to give them
access to more to make their lives more
prosperous is fundamentally a bad thing
and we need to roll it all back and we
can't live this way we just have to go
back to something much more basic
example that didn't consume as much but
you're advocating i think for this other
side of the divide which is no we need
to embrace new technology uh whatever it
may be we need to look at the data on
this we need to look at the numbers
and we need to try to find a world where
we can have a much greener planet but
people's lifestyles aren't suffering as
a consequence of that and perhaps both
are actually achievable now why is it
that you think this divide is emerging i
would think that green activists if they
wanted to sway hearts and minds would be
much on board with the latter with
saying you know we're not saying you can
necessarily have it all but you can have
something pretty close to it all if we
actually embrace the science and the
technology a lot of people don't seem to
want to do that
um i think it's good i think it's good
that we're seeing divide because
actually if you look at traditional
environmentalism which tends to be kind
of
um you know based in wealthy western
nations that are very well developed um
actually it's always had this strange
kind of idyllic idea of going back to
nature and it's also had this strange
kind of separation from humans as if
humans are not part of nature but i've
always said you know social justice
issues should be part of
environmentalism because people matter
too
and um i've also always said that we
can't deny other countries the right to
develop now that now that we're actually
getting to that stage and you have got
you know green groups and ngos rama
galengio saying to these countries no we
don't want you to have fossil fuels we
also don't want you to have nuclear so
we're going to give you a few solar
panels and i'm kind of saying that's
it's not fair and it's actually kind of
immoral that's not what we had in order
to develop a higher quality of life
we didn't get access to education and
modern agriculture and and health care
and infrastructure in order to access
things like health and education we
didn't get that from a little bit of
intermittent power that's the problem
right we burned huge amounts of fossil
fuels help to help to cause climate
change um and now we can't tell those
countries that they can't have it and
what you're what you'll hear in the
environmental movement and i hear this
almost on a daily basis is
this you know people are happy and it's
this really awful um
view that people have of people that
live in poverty where they think they
live hand to mouth and really simply
is somehow happier than we are and
actually you know
not you know my parents migrated here
from a little village in the punjab in
india where they have no electricity
don't have access to health care or
medication or education rice farmers uh
they're struggling wise farmers because
drought is becoming more prevalent
they're probably going to have to
migrate soon and i'm not happy
they have have children they don't know
whether their children are going to make
it to adulthood it's the reality of how
billions of people around the world live
you know um because they don't have a
high quality of life it's this kind of
constant
pushing of this idea that well they live
on the land you know so it's natural and
they're happy you know when you live on
the land there's a lot of
risks involved you know you might get
wild animals coming in and stealing your
children or your crops or you might get
you know diseases that over here we're
just we we're protected from not saying
that there isn't some balance maybe we
did kind of not over develop but you
know um streets where there's no trees
on them and there's lots of you know
there's too much concrete i understand
people see that and they think oh it
would be better to have the other side
these are two extremes and we've got to
just have a really balanced view and
think well how can we develop and still
just bit as sustainably as possible so
the earth still clean for example that's
where i keep landing at nuclear
because it doesn't contribute massively
to air pollution right whereas fossil
fuels do so it's almost a no-brainer i'd
much rather live next to a nuclear plant
which just releases water vapor then a
coal-fired power plant we all know that
right we all if we
and actually the uk we we often import
coal right when it's not windy or sunny
enough and that like that generation
drops we import coal from other
countries but we would never have a
coal-fired power station here can you
imagine the protest if we tried to open
one so kind of outsourcing that cost
other places usually where you know it's
kind of poor people having to live there
because they can't afford to move away
and they
have all these health issues from the
consequence of our consumption so i
understand people see that and they
think to blame and they kind of
self-flagellate and they bring
themselves and they think people we
deserve to suffer i just think a bit
where they then think we deserve to
suffer it's completely wrong and it's
about kind of satisfied and what you'll
find now is a lot of younger
environmentalists who've grown up with
the reality of climate change and also
grown up with the understanding of what
it is to have this great and easy
accessible tech
but they want the tech right there's a
younger generation they want all of that
they want the online world and they want
their phone they kind of are looking
more for a balance so if you offer them
a solution like nuclear energy which is
significant because most of our missions
are from energy the way that we we use
energy and produce electricity then they
will take it and so that divide is very
clear i think in a generational way and
we're kind of it's almost the young
fighting fighting the old in a lot of
ways and that's my experience as well of
sort of people that had to shout me down
now and i'm just saying to them you had
your chance it didn't work things got
worse it's time for you to step out of
the way actually well let me ask you one
more question before you go um watching
the extinction rebellion protests this
week here in london
when you watch them now more as an
outsider than you certainly were before
do you think that these hard-line groups
are doing more harm than good in the way
that they're promoting their cause
i think that we did immense good in the
beginning because i spent about a decade
talking about climate change giving
books on it um
coming up with a lot of um denial about
it and it was only when i got involved
with this it's rebellion and in that you
know they've only been around a few
years and in that kind of year
shift that happened because of ignis
rebellion and fridays for the future
that was really important it did get it
on the agenda even during the pandemic
people's concern about the environment
has remained high because of the work
that this group these groups did
but now it does seem like they're just
bank hanging out the same tune
they've got i think the conversation
needs to move on i mean i said this when
i was in accenture villain i said i
think it's time for the conversation to
move on and they said no because that's
dilution is what you know what we want
which is kind of a fundamental change of
the system and i think that is something
that people should be aware of because i
think a lot of people come up to these
protests really well meaning if they do
are worried and they genuinely do just
want the action
but they're being led by a group that
essentially just wants an overhaul of a
political system more than it wants
action on climate change i mean that i
know they're not going to like me saying
that it's very basically what they stand
for if you look at their demand which is
citizen assemblies to replace government
it's what they want that is what they've
always wanted whereas um all the people
are turning up almost all the people
that are turning up to these events and
getting involved and even getting
arrested actually you just want action
for the future they want clean air they
want you know which is not to be a thing
they don't want to see wildfires they
don't want children to suffer it's very
basic for them they haven't thought
about the messaging that they're getting
behind and i think partly that's because
there aren't other groups really in this
space so they're just going to the one
dominant group but i think people should
really question stop and question um you
know and consider that you know i did
this right i was in the group i was
right in the core group
with messaging working out what they
were standing for and ultimately when i
realized that it was less about climate
change and more about system change i i
stepped away you know because i wanted
to talk about solutions and there was
not space to talk about solutions in
that group besides the system change
which is what they believe is the
fundamental problem which i would say is
actually very unscientific and you know
and actually there's so much research
about how economic growth
lifts people out of poverty i don't
think we should deny that i think it's
dangerous to deny that and that is
exactly what these groups are doing
because they don't like the idea of more
development even though they have
the privilege
been doing this development their entire
lives and they have healthy children yes
they're worried about climate change
impacts on their children but they have
healthy children because of this
development of life and i realize that's
quite a complicated thing to hold in
your head that there's more than one
thing going on there but guess what the
world is a complicated place and if we
don't grow up and fit
we will be having this exact same
discussion in 20 years and that does
worry me and i don't think i can do it
that long so yeah so let's try and
change the conversation
zion thank you so much for joining us on
spectator tv
finally the summer is i hate to break it
to you nearly over but there's still
time for a getaway at home our columnist
toby young decided to follow his beloved
qpr for a tour of the northeast and
write about his holiday for the magazine
this week
hi toby can you tell us where you went
and how it went
yes um i took my two youngest sons aged
13 and 14
um to the northeast of england um
partly just to get out of london and
have a holiday because we're not going
abroad this year for obvious reasons um
but partly because um qpr
the team we support um had two away
games on the trot one in hull on the
saturday and then another one on the
wednesday in middlesbrough uh so we
thought we'd just head up to hull
and um stick around uh for the
middlesbrough game um and take in a
couple of seaside resorts uh like uh uh
scarborough and whitby um
on the way and one of the reasons for
doing that kate is because
we
missed out on attending any football
games uh last season
because
they were all played in closed stadiums
um and we're trying to make up for that
by going to as many as we possibly can
this year including as many away games
as we can so this was very much in
keeping with um that plan well toby i
don't think you're alone in wanting to
make up for lost time i think a lot of
us feel very similarly
so about this match this came after your
experience of watching millwall play a
few weeks ago and you said that there
were hundreds of police officers scraps
in the streets nasty stuff how was this
matching comparison
after the millwall game there was a bit
of rgb g and the millwall fans were
seemingly responsible for that and my
wife and
my youngest child age 13 were caught up
in that actually my my eldest son who's
16 was too and at one point he had to um
sort of put his arms around my wife and
sort of turn his back
to the
sort of fighting fans to protect her and
that was you know a little bit hairy
but nothing like that happened um at
either the hull game or the middlebury
game and i told my children ahead of
time that um
people in the north
were much friendlier and warmer
generally than people in the south um
and
actually the reaction of the opposing
team's fans bore that out so when we had
dinner after the hull match with a
professor at tull university he very
kindly invited us to dinner um and we
didn't have time to go back to the hotel
to get changed beforehand so we had to
make our way to this restaurant you know
on the other side of hull uh wearing our
qpr shirts and but actually every hull
fan we encountered um was incredibly
friendly and sort of congratulated us on
on a well-deserved win and and said you
know how delighted they were that uh we
traveled so far to the game and what a
good game it had been and so forth but
they were all incredibly friendly there
wasn't a hint of hostility because we
were supporting a team that had just
beaten them three nil so so
i was very pleased about that because um
it did i think provide my sons with some
insight into just how how nice
people in the north of england are
compared to people in the south well how
far are you going to take this
friendliness point um are you going to
do a broad stroke here and say that the
northerners are simply friendlier than
the southerners
um
yeah i mean i don't want to push it too
far um but uh i think it is generally
true that um
uh
southerners um tend to be a bit more
standoffish
and um uh uh more inclined to respect
one another's privacy and um not engage
you in conversations uh in pubs and
shops and so forth as readily uh
certainly people in the northeast do um
uh particularly if you're with children
uh i mean i don't want to um you know
talk uh
too much about the sentimentality of
northerners boris johnson got into
trouble after all for describing i think
uh liverpudlians as um as uh overly
sentimental um but um being with kids um
makes everyone much friendlier um and
we certainly experienced that on our our
tour
you're a london family many of our
viewers will be from the north of
england and might be amused to hear uh
what your son's first thoughts were of
the sainsburys and whole
yeah well my youngest son
when we first saw
a sort of sainsbury's superstar on the
outskirts of hull um
said that he had no idea
that uh sainsbury's existed outside of
england
making the kind of i think fairly common
mistake of kind of confusing london with
england and everywhere outside london as
a foreign country um uh and that became
a sort of running gag um you know
whenever he saw a mcdonald's or a kfc or
a morrisons after that was like i had no
idea they had a mcdonald's outside
england um but
uh we did we did um i mean one of the
striking things when you when you go on
a tour of the provinces um is um just
how many
similar recognizable household brands
there are on high streets it's not the
dissimilarity that's surprising but the
similarity but the difference at least
between hull and middlesbrough and
london is that uh while there were lots
of you know alternatives kind of lower
down the retail hierarchy to
well-known household names um there
didn't seem to be um uh alternatives
above them in the kind of retail food
chain so um you know no organic grocers
or artisanal bakeries um uh that kind of
thing and i got into trouble uh in a
coffee shop in um whitby when i uh asked
the guy behind the counter for a cortado
and i got a blank look and i explained
in what i thought was a helpful way that
it was a cross between a double
macchiato and a latte and he said meat
as far as i'm concerned coffee's just
coffee
and my children were very embarrassed
about that toby i'm not convinced that
even baristas in london would know what
a cortado is i was a barista for years
giving coffee to new york city commuters
and uh to be honest maybe this is a
criticism of my time in the job but i
don't even know what that word was i
didn't until i until i read your column
so i'm gonna side with the baristas on
this one um well after your travels toby
and with a few weeks left of the summer
holidays for people to get their trips
in where would you recommend people go
well um we weren't
wildly impressed by scarborough um which
seemed a little bit
seedy um and uh the seafront seemed to
be taken up almost entirely um by
amusement arcades which of course my 13
and 14 year old were delighted by but um
might not appeal to some of our older
readers but whitby was absolutely
delightful um uh really nice um and um
uh not kind of um
not not not spoiled in the same way um
lots of nice fish and chip shops locally
owned not not high street branches um uh
uh that we went to the captain cook
museum which i thought was pretty well
done uh we were actually looking for
traces of my ancestors the mawsoms who
um i'd been told by a cousin um were
referred to in this museum because they
apparently built captain cook's ship
that he um first sailed to australia in
but we couldn't find any trace of the
mawson family in the captain cook museum
and my fourteen-year-old joke that that
was probably because
some protesters last year had discovered
their links with the slave parade and
that if i looked in the harbour i might
find a statue of my great great great
grandfather i don't think it actually
did have any links with a slave i should
stress but it was quite a funny joke
and those were toby's travel tips toby
thanks for joining us
and that's it for this week if you
enjoyed this episode why not subscribe
to the spectators youtube channel so you
never miss out just click the subscribe
button at the bottom of this video and
the bell icon to make sure you never
miss an episode thanks for watching and
do join us again next week
[Music]
you